much much more serious people than the
journalists in the establishment press
are looking into this not just judicial
watch not just rana and kaylee
also the attorney general we are very
pleased to report
that the honey badger attorney general
bill barr himself
has come out and directed u.s attorneys
to pursue
significant allegations of voting
irregularities
this is great news one because it's
acknowledging
there were voting irregularities we
don't know quite how widespread they
were
but they were significant much much
much more significant than anything we
have seen at least in my lifetime
probably since going back to tammany
hall or going back to
lbj stealing that senate seat in texas
back in 1948.
so that's great on the on the one front
you got the doj acknowledging that
really happened
but then on the other you see bill barr
is being careful here he doesn't want to
appear irregular himself so he says
serious allegations should be handled
with great care
species speculative fanciful or
far-fetched claims should not be a basis
for initiating federal inquiries
they're saying look if it's some wild
accusation there's no evidence for it or
it's a very minor
allegation that really wouldn't have
swung anything we're not going to spend
federal resources on that
but for significant claims of fraud with
evidence
we're going to investigate very
thoroughly this is pretty important
i've noticed especially watching jay
tapper but watching people on the left
like him or watching even some people on
the right
people are very impassioned right now
and and i understand why i mean
especially on the right because the
people on the right think that the
election was stolen
you'll notice i have not been quite as
impassioned
quite as screaming from the rooftops
making big claims and
i am making the same claims now that i
made a month before the election
which is namely the mail-in ballots have
posed this
singular problem the crooked
cities such as philadelphia and detroit
have posed a singular problem
we're not we didn't know on election
night who the winner was we still don't
know who the winner of the election is
it's going to go to court the legal
process is going to play out
this has happened before in american
history it will happen again in american
history
and the courts will decide who wins and
people still might not be happy with
that they might say the courts didn't do
enough or they might say the courts did
too much
but that is the way the process will be
playing out
one way or another and so we want to be
cool-headed here we want to be patient
as the left is screaming call him the
president-elect paul biden the president
we have to tune those guys out we have
to be careful too on the right because
the right might say
look at this explosive evidence of some
fraud and you say okay i'm going to look
at it
but i'm not going to just accept it you
know and get my hopes up necessarily
because
if that full support or even if it was
true but there's no way to prove it
that's not going to affect the outcome
in the end we are in a very
precarious situation right now the only
thing we can do
is wait we can stand by the president
first of all we cannot refer to joe
biden as the president-elect i think
it's preposterous
and silly liberal republicans like mitt
romney court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism
ought to be ashamed of themselves for
doing that we shouldn't do that neither
should we pop champagne ourselves and
say trump's getting reelected
necessarily
we're in a precarious holding pattern
and we're going to know a lot more next
week once that legal process
is playing out i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you